now we're going to turn to Iran where
protests against the Islamic regime have
been going on for weeks now the
government is still trying to crack down
it has confirmed their first death
sentence for a protester someone accused
of setting fire to a government building
the charge enmity against God Charlie
dagatus following the latest protests
including a series of walkouts that
began this morning
defying the threat of execution they're
still demonstrating on the streets of
Iran this was last Friday
Iran's revolutionary Court handed down
the first official death sentence to an
anti-government protester on Sunday
an ominous warning for more than 15
thousand Iranians currently under arrest
the Iranian regime said the rebels need
to be taught a hard lesson it follows a
brutal Crackdown on demonstrations that
have raged for months triggered by the
death of 22 year old Masa amini in
September allegedly beaten while in
custody of so-called morality police
accused of wearing her head scarf
improperly
it became a Flashpoint that erupted into
Nationwide protests
chance of death to the dictator on a
scale Iran has not seen in decades
burning their hijabs and chopping off
their hair defiance
activists believe there is little hope
of a fair trial for the thousands
detained now awaiting sentencing
human rights groups fear that a wave of
execution orders may now follow yet even
in the face of death sentences activists
have called on Iranians to take part in
three days of Nationwide protests
starting today Tony
all right Charlie thank you very much